by way of advice let me ask you if I
were to have a conversation interview
Vladimir Putin and zalinski
individually what should I ask them if
you me and Vladimir Putin are having a
chat what are
good ideas to explore what are good
questions to ask what are good things to
say on or off the mic once again that
could
potentially even slightly lessen the
amount of suffering in the world caused
by this war oh I think if you get an
interview with Vladimir Putin there's
just all sorts of questions you could
ask him and my sense is that Putin is a
straight shooter uh he's also very
knowledgeable about history and he has
simple theories in his head about how
the world works and I think he would
level with you and all you would have to
do is just you know figure figure out
what all the right questions are and
that would not be hard to do right uh
you know you could ask him why was he so
foolish this is for for example why was
he so foolish is to uh uh trust uh
poreno Holland and Merkel uh in the
Minsk
Accords uh you know why after his famous
talk at Munich in 2007 where he made it
clear that he was so unhappy with the
West uh did he continue uh to you know
in a very important way trust the West
why didn't he mobilize uh the Russian
military before late September
20122 uh you know once the negotiations
that we were talking about before uh
involving
istanbull uh and uh Na Tali Ben and once
they broke down you know why didn't he
immediately mobilize more of the Russian
population to fight the war just all
sorts of questions like that and then
you could ask them questions about you
know where uh he sees this one headed uh
what's the best strategy for Russia uh
if the ukrainians will not agree to
neutrality right uh you know people like
John mirer say you'll probably take uh
close to half of Ukraine is that true
does it make sense to take
Odessa and John mimer also has questions
about
China your future relationships with
China yeah I mean one really important
question that I would ask him is if the
United States had basically not driven
you into the arms of the Chinese if
there had been no war over Ukraine and
the United States had and its European
allies had gone a considerable length to
create some sort of security architect
cure in Europe uh that resulted in you
Vladimir Putin having good relations
with Ukraine what would your relations
with China be uh and uh you know how
would you think about that uh so there
there are just plenty of questions you
could ask
him well hope Burns Eternal in my heart
I think probably in Putin's heart and
zelinsky's heart I hope
cuz hope is uh the leap of trust that
we've talked about I think is necessary
for deescalation and for peace well you
realize I have from the beginning argued
for different policies that were all
designed to prevent this war from ever
happening I don't know if you know this
but in 1993 I argued that Ukraine should
keep its nuclear weapons I was probably
the only person in the west who made
that argument and my argument in 1993
this is in foreign affairs was that
there may come the day when Russia
thinks about invading Ukraine and should
that day come it would be very helpful
for preventing War if Ukraine had
nuclear weapons so military might is
essential for maintaining a balance of
power and peace well if you're
interested in deterring an adversary if
I'm worried about you coming after me
the best way to deter you is to have
military might
and if you're Russia and I'm Ukraine I'm
far weaker than you yeah right and
having a nuclear deterrent would be very
effective at convincing you not to
attack me because if you attack me
you're threatening my survival and
that's the one circumstance where it is
likely that I would use nuclear weapons
to defend myself and given the
consequences of nuclear use you would be
reluctant in the extreme to attack me so
that's why I argued in '93 that if
Ukraine kept its nuclear weapons that
made War down the road much less likely
and I believe I was correct and in fact
Bill Clinton who played the key role in
forcing Ukraine to give up its nuclear
weapons now says he has said it publicly
you can find it on YouTube that he made
a mistake doing that furthermore I
argued in
2014 that it made eminently good sense
not to continue to push to bring Ukraine
into NATO because the end result is that
Ukraine would be destroyed and Ukraine
is being destroyed so I was deeply
interested at the time in making sure
that that didn't happen for the good of
the ukrainians not to mention because
stability in Europe is a net positive
for almost everybody involved but people
did not listen to me then
either